so i'll just speak briefly to my report
which is regarding
issues for consideration in relation to
three waters engagement or consultation
i think it's important to note that
while the issue
of
three waters opting in or out
is no doubt significant
legal advice from simpson grierson which
has been provided to councils
does say that in their opinion providing
feedback to government is not a
significant issue and as a result any
engagements undertaken is optional so
it's really for you council to consider
what level and what type of engagement
you wish to undertake on this matter
um a range of different engagement and
consultation is enabled by our
significance and engagement
policy which you adopted as part of the
long-term plan
um
it is really important to note that
given requirements under the local
government act and in our relation to
our significance and engagement policy
that at this point no decision on
whether to opt in or out can be made
without undertaking formal consultation
which would need to take the form of an
amendment to the long-term plan
and that any engagement undertaken in
the meantime could not be the basis of
decision making nevertheless you could
use it to provide feedback to government
undertaking engagement now would give
you a sense of what the community is
thinking on the issue of three waters
however we would advise that
in order for that engagement to be the
most useful possible
you would really want to be presenting
alternative options for which we do not
have all of the full information at this
point
the other option is to present purely
what the government is presenting
on
their proposals and to seek feedback on
that however they've indicated at this
point that they're not seeking that
feedback and that they're likely to
undertake
engagement themselves at a national
level
i've outlined in my report some of the
risks to undertaking engagement now and
on the flip side to not undertaking
engagement it's important to note that
if we do engage now we will still be
required under current legislation to
consult again further
um on the other hand this may be the
only opportunity to engage at a local
level and we are not yet clear on what
the government is going to be requiring
um they may well change the legislative
requirements but this paper deals with
the legislation as it stands at this
point so happy to answer any questions
on this matter
thank you that's a very comprehensive
report right i'm going to open up for
questions
counselors
no that's obviously uh councillor sopa
thank you mr chair i just wanted to ask
scriannan
um as i understand it what the
government has asked for by the end of
september
is for us to consider the impact of the
reforms on our communities to seek
clarification and to provide feedback
the reality of especially with the
covert situation is that the end of
september may not be at all practical to
provide the feedback we would like to
provide
um and i did see in your report
a suggestion that we could write to
government and say that was an
unrealistic time frame and suggest that
we could not provide feedback until
october
which would give us time for a workshop
on the matter
and a discussion as to whether a an
engagement
um for the print for the
reasons of
um
[Music]
as you
suggested taking the the
tenor of their community at the moment
on the issue and perhaps acting as a
pre-engagement for a future consultation
would then be a possibility
is is that a
is that a realistic pathway that we
could take to write to government and
say
september end of september is
unrealistic for what you're asking we
would not be able to provide feedback
and
requests for clarification until
end of october
so my understanding is that the southern
and otago mayors have indeed signaled to
government that they believe more time
is needed i'm certainly saying that in
order to undertake engagement from a
practical just technical delivery point
of view that can't
be done in time
to enable you to feedback at the end of
september
as to whether and how government would
receive feedback beyond that point
i would um probably defer to the chief
executive to give her thoughts on that
matter as to whether the government
would receive feedback at a later date
so would the end of october be realistic
if we did decide to do engagement along
the lines that you've suggested mainly
um
[Music]
online
facebook type engagements acceptance for
that to happen before the end of october
for us to then feedback
i believe so yes
okay
mr chair if the chief executive's got
any comment there that would be useful
okay i see uh the general manager of
infrastructure aaron has
got a hand up aaron
um look i just wanted to clarify just
around the um the feedback portion
during the eight week process at the
moment
um that at the previous infrastructure
committee meeting we did have a
discussion around three waters reform um
and compile a list of comments and
questions to go back to central
government during the eight week period
now that obviously doesn't mean we can't
go back with with further questions and
comments but we we have already
initiated that process
thank you
um
councillor clark
councillor clark yeah thank you just a
couple of comments in relation to
uh what we just heard from staff um for
aaron have we got any response to the
questions that we put to dia
at the last meeting
um sorry councillor clark i'm just
bringing my video back up
uh look well i'm trying to just sorry
i'm just trying to find out a time frame
we haven't had an answer back yet um and
i'll follow up around the time frame of
when we can expect those
okay
and the other the other issue is just
some comment against
the advice that we've given by rhiannon
it seems to me as though we have an
unlevel playing field here
i forwarded to all elected members and
key staff members a couple days ago
a document out of fonaray district
council
and the key piece of information on that
document was that
when each council signed up its
memorandum of understanding
earlier in the year and received its
funding from government
those mius lapsed on the
30th of june this year
and the and the documents from wongarei
show that there was a cabinet paper that
came along shortly after that that
basically said that
um
there was an expectation that councils
were in
uh the reform
and if they wanted to be out had they
had to
exercise the exit clause to get out
and i think it's important to
acknowledge that because when i speak to
my emotion later on that's one of the
key things is that there seems to be
confusion amongst many males that i've
interfaced with who think that they are
still
neither in or out they're sitting in
limbo and have yet to make a decision
where in fact the government
uh buy that cabinet paper has the view
that we're already in unless you want to
opt out
um just on that point and rhiannon do
you want to confirm this
with the
lgnz legal advice that's attached
it clearly states that
council is neither in or out
and that decision either way
has to be made in fact they emphasized
the point
that to opt out
as a significant decision and would
require the same amount of consultation
as opting in they've made that quite
clear and i imagine
the lawyers that prepared that would
have understood
any other papers that were lying around
in fact papers can be papers but unless
they have gone through parliament and
being
confirmed
they are only um
papers so
rhiannon do you want to comment on that
is the opting in opting out option
only only to say that yes that's that's
the basis on which my report is written
the simpson greece and legal advice that
has been provided and that is their view
that neither opting in or opting out can
be done without consultation having
taken place
but that it is not possible to undertake
consultation within the time frame for
the government's feedback
so obviously uh the councils that have
done the formal opting out have actually
and not done the full consultation
process as
mentioned before uh are open to
judicial review
because they haven't done that correct
process councillor clark
just to clarify that position so brienne
just told us that
the
simpson griezmann position is that
to
make a decision and i understand that we
would have to consult because it's a
significant decision and i understand
that fully understand that
what i was suggesting was there is a
government belief that we are by default
in the process unless we use the out
clause
the exit option and so that's clearly an
area of dispute because um but it makes
no difference i'm not talking about
going down the track of doing a a um
consultation under the under the uh act
or under our policy because that's a
quite a hefty sort of excise but most
the councils that i've engaged with
are going through what they call
engagement so they're just looking to
get some initial feedback from their
community about about where we're
heading with us and i think rhiannon's
paper talks that that's an option as
opposed to consultation
that's correct
thanks mr chair look i just wanted to
clarify the other part of simpson
grierson's
opinion that i think is very significant
is that they do make the point
and you've made it yourself in a
different way that legislation is
currently in place passed by parliament
which binds this government and
ourselves
until that legislation is changed that
legislation rules and must be abided by
and simpson griezmann's opinion is quite
clear on that and you are open to
judicial review
if you try and act contrary to that so
simpson griezmann is quite clear
the government
is bound by the parliamentary
legislation currently in place
just as we are and that parliamentary
legislation clearly has the provision
for consultation
before major decisions
so i think let's not go down the rat
hole
of whether or not
we can opt out or opt-in or whether the
government
has a cabinet paper that uh councillor
clark says he's discovered
the legislation is in place and we have
a very specific
legal opinion that says we and the
government are bound by that legislation
and remember the government no
government in itself is parliament
parliament is separate from government
parliament has passed a piece of
legislation currently in place
that binds the current government
only putting through another piece of
legislation that would overturn that
changes that legislation
thank you councillor sopa
councillor clark
yeah my final word on that issue is the
simpson grass and opinion
states councils are not required to
engage in order to respond
and that's true
so the issue is do we engage
and rihanna's saying that door's open as
opposed to consult
and and i'd have some issue with what
leslie just said i guess
because
the local government act is quite
rightly an act of parliament that binds
us
it doesn't bind the crown
so the crown don't have to consult on
three waters but we somewhere along the
line will have to consult if we are
required to make a decision and that's
not my debate if you look at my nose
emotion doesn't say anything about
consultation it talks about engagement
doing what some other counselors are
doing to say hey this is a big issue we
need to be on the front foot with our
committees or with our committees and do
some initial engagement don't need to
make a decision let's just do some work
so they have some surety that we're not
sitting on our hands
um one thing with engagement uh
that that if you were a rate player you
would you basically want to know how is
it going to affect me now
one of the key things that we don't know
and would seem foolish going out to the
public without this information
is
what's my build going to be
well they haven't
the the government have not clarified
this part
in scotland they did not hand the
billing
over to the new entity
it was still it is still being done by
councils
and it's done according to capital
values it's a it's a tax
so
if you apply that to our current rating
um
value the way we do water is 80 percent
a targeted rate 20 general rate so what
that does it sort of offloads
the effect on lower capital properties
now
do we know what the new entity is
how it's going to build no we don't
so the rate payer would not have a clue
what his bill is going to be is it going
to be more is going to be less
so look engagement
with this one i see
is reasonably futile just because
it is the government's
proposition if it was our long-term plan
and we were putting forward our ideas
then i can see why we'd want to
fine-tune our ideas so they meet
the right payers needs
this is a wee bit different so i see
engagement
um could be a waste of a lot of time and
not achieve
anything that's just my view on that yes
michael
thank you councillor
the
the questions you posed there around the
engagement and the information we would
need to engage
there are
two two items which are outstanding
from my perspective and i believe we
would need a workshop with councillors
to actually get a good understanding for
the councillors on these these two
components uh one is of course
the the cost to the right our ratepayers
of invercargill and what impact that may
have on them and you're quite right we
do not have the information available
that is an outstanding item
the other
impact is the the cost associated to
an impact for icc
from that perspective as as a council
and then again
that flow on effect to the rate powers
of invercargill through that channel as
well so those two impacts we have been
doing some modelling and getting some
information
from from the
dia and we do have quite a bit of
information now to hand that could take
council through workshop
but as i say
going out to engagement that is there is
an area that is difficult to actually
take out because it is a grey area at
the moment in relation to the
information being provided
thank you michael
right council counselors any other
further questions or discussion on
no
right there is uh a recommendation
the recommendation that the committee
received the report for the three waters
engagement
or consultation matters for
consideration
noting the following issues
a b c d e can i please have someone move
that
i'll move i'll move that to get it
together
to get it to get it on the table um mr
chia i'm just i'm just wondering if it
needs um a number three to say that um
council
um undertakes to arrange a workshop in
the near future to discuss this matter
further i think a workshop would be um a
useful way to progress things a little
no i take that i take that on but i'll
move i'll move it the way it is to get
it on the table
okay
right um
to add
a
note that council does undertake a
workshop
so within the next two weeks yes
i would see that as sensible
yeah i'll move i'll i'll move i'll move
the original with someone more second
and then we can move an amendment to add
that point
to arrange a workshop
can i have a second to please
yeah i'll do that
thank you councillor abbott right would
you like to move that amendment
councillors
yes i'll move an amendment to add
the
we can probably add another bullet point
to e to say um
council undertakes to arrange a workshop
on three waters issues
within the next 14 days
thank you
second animation chair
right
okay
so we have that so with the
added
note 3 of a workshop um i'm going to put
that motion all those in favor
all right hi
hi
again
that is carried
right that takes us now on to
counselor clerk notice a motion
counselor clerk
hello council [ __ ]
councillor clark might not uh realize
he's muted
thank you
the key issues that it seems that our
community and other communities and
around the country have wanted some
engagement with not consultation
and that may really be that counselor
sober's idea or suggestion of a workshop
that runs ahead of this still fits with
my notice of motion
um there are four or five key issues
that they want to know about and it's
not drilling down to the
uh
to the water reports out of scotland or
anything like that what they want to
know is is there economy of scale that
benefits the city council
our center council
can the water entity recruit and retain
enough water specialists to run the
program the da advice to that is no
can the current industry upscale 200 to
deliver the service outcomes dia's
response to that is no
what are the actual costs for three
waters in a household 10 years from now
and michael alluded to that
both from our perspective if we went
alone or if we're part of the award
empty
um
fourthly or fifthly who owns the assets
well that's already clear councils
retain the ownership of the assets but
the more important issue is who governs
and controls the
water entity from those two strategic
groups of being set up
and and finally
the issue that hasn't been resolved is
how will growth in some cities
override the renewal programs that might
be needed in this city
and will we cross subsidise that growth
in other areas
so from my end
um supporting the motion i don't know
why we're dancing around these key
issues with the government while the
government plugs a hole um staff who
have spoken today will know that getting
information out of dia is like pulling
hands to you um and so it's really
important to know that it's not just me
or or one or two councils it's uneasy
about this whole reform program i can
advise you that there is a weekly zoom
link with 33 mayors in the country i was
recently by asked what i want to be part
of and i declined that
um
christchurch has made it clear in the
last couple days as they did two weeks
ago
that if they have an opt-out vote
tomorrow
they are out
farmer a far north kaipara westland and
waikiki macarei have all done exercise
to engage and have made statements to
the minister saying we won't be
railroaded on this we want time to talk
to our communities we're not talking
about full-time consultation we just
want to have the ability that the
community's not left out of the picture
why macarena and christchurch are
currently engaging
christchurch has had four thousand
submissions in five days so there's
clearly a huge amount of interest in in
three waters that's why maccari may have
said to me they've been overwhelmed by
the feedback they've got
um
so i think it's important that we we do
make a statement to the minister
that says that we don't want to be
pushed through to a decision that she
might make
late september early
october
at the moment we're sort of we're
reliant on on or some some councils and
mayors from the groups that i go to seem
to be reliant on the dia and the
government's commitment
that post the end of september mr maheta
will advise the pathway forward
and we will have an opportunity to
consult
um with our communities
most the mayors i engage with don't
believe that will come to fruition
um they believe that the minister is um
lining up the political
risk of mandating
and so i don't believe the minister will
take away our requirements to consult i
think what's heading towards us
is that they will move a regulation to
mandate us all in
in recent comments by mayor golf would
indicate that auckland's also not
prepared to be involved
um
so um what i wanted to do is to follow
the path of waimakariri
and and happy to have a workshop
because that's what they had and then
lead to some very simple documentation
it doesn't have to be too complex and
just get a feel from our community um
they've opened it up by way of some
pop-up sections which councillors and
staff combined can certainly listen to
the views coming back some of those
views will still be a little bit
distorted by lack of information
but it's unrealistic to consult at this
stage because the amount of
documentation we put out
already overwhelms many counselors and
would overwhelm
the public in the same way
so
and the key piece of information which
michael alluded to was the issue
and this is what ratepayers really want
to know is
if i go forward in the next 10 years
will my
water rates be cheaper if the council
goes it alone or will it be cheaper if
it goes to the water entity
and my look at all the paperwork and
having listened to a couple of emails
that i got from michael
um friday last week thursday last week
is that it would suggest that
our going out alone will be a cheaper
option
and that's yet to be firmed up
but it's a sad indictment that we are a
couple three weeks away from the end of
september
and the ministry or dia still can't give
us that financial equation because well
like michael quite rightly says
um
we need that's the most critical
decision that householders want to know
the other critical decision which the
dia refuses to respond to is will we
have water meters so this is not just an
auckland scenario
fong array's got
water meters and had them for quite some
time
carpety coast has got them and central
otago buys monresi they've had them for
12 years
and that they are worth their weight in
gold but they are controversial because
what happens is that the people who want
to be frugal with their water as you can
be frugal with power
end up with a much smaller bill than
those that
you know might have teenage kids that
have half hair showers and use a lot of
water and so that has supporters but has
people that are not supportive of it as
well
and so i think it's time for us to go
out and have some discussion with our
community
um
i think the staff have done an excellent
job paying the paper that's in front of
us
and i think preparing a document that
subsequently goes out after the workshop
would be less work for them and and
quite achievable i think it's something
we should do
um so hence my uh
putting forward the notice which
basically doesn't talk about um anything
to do with
consultation it's all about engagement
and it's all about uh giving the
minister a message that reinforces what
the mayors on the south on
um have written to the minister twice
recently we wrote a week and a half ago
the cannery region zone five wrote about
three weeks ago saying we want to pause
and the response today has been no reply
and feedback i'm getting from some of
the key mayors that are involved with
engaged
with the minister's office
is that there will be no decision on
this she's she's not prepared to pause
the program
so i think it's time for us to put a bit
of line in the sand
and to do what we need to do with our
community
thank you
councillors
here's your mission
you worship you're on mute
i support they'll be on this
train over water
but um i know i was interested that i
don't have any of you tuned into these
extracts
trust
from tasmania and victoria
they
uh put forward
quite a convincing case it was simple
which shouldn't
um some measure
by some measuring water use
and that's a patch for
the huge infrastructural cost
but
you don't know that until you've
got an example and they had um
really good returns they were saying
things like oh this this wall is the
best thing we've ever had
our um surplus last year was 20 million
and it looks like it's shaped up for a
similar
size income
you know they're going to put
quite a convincing case i feel
that um
still
good fight we've gotta
you know
give us the best shot
but um we're up against
the iranian government
it's pretty tough
to win veterans and magazines
uh just a point ringy should the notice
of motion be moved in second absolutely
and what did you say to that
sorry what
um i'm just uh asking should the motion
be
moved the notice of motion
i'm still
open to discussion
counselors over
thanks mr chair
um look i've read the notice of motion
and i just don't see the point
of the notice emotion at the current
time
especially not that we've
there's there's important conversations
to be had about the water issue
and yes of course it's
it's
one of the
the biggest
issues council have faced um in quite a
number of years
but
i'm very hesitant to be seen as one of
the councils who is starting to toss our
toys out of the cot
when we can keep having conversations
we've already been part of
writing
to the minister
pointing out these issues and questions
etc
erin's confirmed that we
at the last meeting did have some issues
we had asked questions on we've arranged
a workshop where we can discuss the very
important issue and all
[Music]
if you like come up to speed in exactly
the same place on where we have answers
on various issues i i'm
i'm just struggling to see at the moment
the point
of the notice of motion
um
adding anything to the
the issue
that we haven't already catered for we
know that engaging with our community
will be useful when we have more
information
to engage with
we know that there will probably be a
need for a full consultation at some
point under the current legislation
i i just feel that the notice of motion
is
getting us into um
into joining a sort of extreme no no you
can't touch water
view that is just not realistic and
today in today's um
environment
thank you councillor sopa
right before i handed over to counsellor
uh yes councillor arnold
um yeah i um i support the motion
because the first thing i see that it
does is that it sort of um
it says that it basically says what
we're going to do rather than being told
what we're going to do
and it gives us
it says says it says to government that
this is the timeline that we're going to
work to to do these things that we're
going to do and yes councillor services
this is the biggest decision that we've
ever probably ever had to make
uh certainly in my five years
that
affects an asset that's owned by a
community it's been built by communities
being maintained by a community
and i just see that it's something that
we need to manage and
the councils that are obviously um
thinking the same way that we are i mean
these are not minor councils you know
that's what we said i heard phil goff
the other day
and that's the auckland council the
biggest one in the country obviously and
uh they're moving down the same path
that we're heading toward that way as
towards what um
councillor clark's motion uh pretty much
says so
these are this is christchurch as well
these aren't minor councils um this just
assists common sense it just means that
it puts the
the process
in their hands of what we're going to do
in the time that we need to do it as i
see it so i support the motion and i'm
happy to
to
second it if necessary or
okay
that's all thank you
thank you councilman
councillor manson
hello bex
oh there we go
um
when i think about this
i'm kind of torn and
um
when nobby's referred to the group of 33
councils that are having a discussion
about this
via zoom you know i think that's really
good i was a little bit surprised to
hear that he declined to be part of it i
would have thought that being in that
tent would have been a good plan um
but the thing that
holds me back from agreeing to take
action as an individual council rather
than as part of a collective which is
what we've already done
um and in several instances that have
been um explained already uh with our
fellow otago and southland councils
but
the councils that have gone out by
themselves and taken action or done
things sounds like there's about a half
dozen of them
they don't actually make up the majority
the majority of councils are still
having conversations even if that's with
amongst themselves
and positioning themselves or talking
about what the options are it seems to
me that the majority of councils are
waiting to see what happens at the end
of the month to see what it is that um
that the minister puts forward as the
pathway
and it seems to me that that is the long
game and that is the smart game in this
situation
um
i feel like this set of motions is
really um
well i think nobody even said it himself
we've already said these things more or
less via our collective statement with
the other councils and i'd rather see us
be part of a collective which has more
power i think than we do as an
individual council
with any actions that we take or
movements that we make
so i'm not sure i would support this
uh the only thing i guess and this kind
of harks back to the previous discussion
around engagement and information and
stuff like that i have noticed that a
lot of other councils on their websites
have some information already about the
three waters stuff
and i think that possibly it does feel a
little bit like a void to the community
when we don't have any information even
if it's just a list of links of where
you can go to get information about
what's going on
i certainly couldn't find any on our
website and i just wonder whether as a
first step that that might be something
that we can do
um
so that our community knows that it is
something that we're talking about
uh and being proactive about and
playing a part in
thank you rebecca
any other further comments
look as cheering before i pass over to
councillor clark for his summary
um and before we move and second this um
just like to say a few words regarding
what we're doing here so bear with me on
this so with regards to three waters
councils
been instructed by the dia
and lgnz's legal advisors that we are
currently in a two-month
fact-finding period
until the end of september
this is to allow for questions and to
provide feedback regardless of what
other councils may have done
these instructions are quite clear
counselor clerks notice a motion request
that council advised the minister that
icc will not be making any decision in
regards to participation
in the proposed three-water reform
program
until it it can engage with its
community
of these matters of
significance now one might question
the effective purpose of this two-month
q a period but it is the government that
is proposing the three waters reform and
at this stage we have been asked to
participate
in discussions
this period of participation does not
require council to make decisions
regarding opting in or out
of the reforms master plan
the government is very aware of the
local authority legal requirements to
consult with their communities regarding
decisions of significance
and in a december cabinet paper
they identified
statutory
obstacles for councils to make
the decisions with regards to three
waters one of these obstacles is section
130 of the lga
which prevents councils divesting in
water assets
there is a copy of section 130 in the
staff report
the other obstacles are the complex
consultation requirements
and associated long-term plan amendments
these are listed
in the staff report as well along
with the 24 to 28 week time period to
make something like that happen
the december cabinet paper also shows
that government proposed a local
government three waters reform amendment
bill
now if that bill is agreed it would
address those statutory obstacles
listed in section 130
and would also remove or amend the
detailed legislative requirements around
consultation and long-term planning
they state that this would lead to a fit
for purpose consultation process
that sets out how councils would engage
with their communities and make
decisions
now the key point from this
is that the local government three
waters reform bill
has not yet been agreed
so i refer this committee to paragraphs
seven and eight of the legal report and
counselor sopra has touched on these
and that advice says well i'm going to
simplify it in
cheers language
calm the farm
parliament can change the law
but until those laws are changed
both central government
and local government must
adhere
to that current law
this means that before this council can
make a decision with regards to a change
in its delivery of its three water
service it must
consult
with its community
there there is nothing of substance
and counselor clark's notice emotion
to advise the minister
and this council needs to stay focused
on what is at hand
and
and maintain
productive dialogue
with the dia
and the other councils
so i just that's the chairman's view on
this i'm now handing over to councillor
clarke
yeah thank you chair and for those uh
views just to clarify some points that
my colleagues have raised um
biggs for you i
i declined the
offer to be part of the 33
mere zoom
because i didn't
think that i had a mandate
um
to be representing a view of this
council
at such a level
while i do have some overlapping roles
of the
with the mayor
i do have some specific um views on
three waters and i'm not a supporter so
i've been quite transparent about that
so i thought it would be inappropriate
for me on behalf of the city to be going
there given that i've got that
i guess predetermined position and it's
not to say that i'm not listening to
what's coming down the tubes
um
it's interesting claire will be able to
help me with this date but i think about
six months ago
we went to a lgnz conference in
wellington
and just about every mayor said that we
need to engage with our community and
the dia gave us a commitment that they
would put together a package for each
council individualistic to that council
that would allow us to go out and and
sort of using their words consult
i specifically asked alan pragnell
when that would be given and he said
soon i said what does that mean he said
a couple of weeks we're now nearly six
months down the track and everybody's
still asking for the information
um
i think the um
you know the fact that we've asked for
questions at the last infrastructure
meeting which is four weeks ago
and we've had no response just tells you
exactly where the dia and the government
are going on this
interesting that
um in a recent webinar which is about
four weeks ago mayor
i had a similar question to one of my
colleagues today was
what options did the dia consider
and the dia advised that they had
considered nine options before they got
to the current one and so he asked for a
copy of that copy those other eight
options so that he could
consider those council clark i must
remind you that you are to
to reply to
what's being debated on in your summary
not to introduce new information
okay
well
just as a final comment
i think what i've suggested um has some
support from the staff paper
it talks about engagement not
significance are not consultation i
think we should have the workshop and go
forward
within the time frames of the
um those emotion which is the 30th of
november which gives us time to
to engage with our community some
councils are asking for referendums
which i don't support i think we should
just engage and do an information share
as waimakariri have done so i'll just
leave it to that
all right thank you council clerk would
you like to move you'll know the motion
i'll do exactly that thank you
and uh we have a secondary counselor
clark's notice a motion
seconded
counselor arnold
right i'm going to put that motion
all those in favor please say hi
all right what i'm gonna do because of
this i'd like each of those counselors
just to raise their hand
so i can see it in front of the screen
one two that's four
five can i have someone confirm five
he is to
can you help me with that myself alan
peter and the mayor
and man
the mia's hand wasn't raised
no i i found silence only
when he said raise your hand counsellors
oh sorry elected members raise their
hands please
so chair can i suggest a division so
that we can be clear about who's voting
which way
okay what i'll do is i'll go i'll raise
also
against those against
no
no
okay
right and those abstaining
uh that would be me i choose to abstain
on this
topic at this time
right we have one abstention okay right
um
clara do you want to do the
numbers
can i just confirm that i've got what i
think i've got counsellors arnold
clark
the mayor
louis
scout
and was it councillor kit
is uh in favor yes he's confirming he
was so that's six votes in favor
sorry
sorry i lost connection i fell off purge
um councillor abbott can i ask how you
vote in relation to this notice of
motion
against
so against is councillor abbott
so um councillors abbott
ludlow sopa
amundsen
poffinger
and i must be missing one one two three
four five
uh councillor crackit is an extension
councillor lush
how are you voting
um
councillor luscious volume has gone
and he's logging out and coming back and
i'm sorry mr chair i can't tell you
uh until councillor lush
comes back online and given that you've
started taking the boat i think you're
required to
give him that opportunity he has come
straight back in so i will ask him again
as
may i just ask a query question i went
offline for about five or ten minutes so
i did not hear the last last about five
ten minutes of the debate can i still
vote
uh yes you can though
thank you
councillor lush can i ask whether you
are voting for or against the notice of
motion i lost the whole volume for about
five minutes the computer fell how did
the vote go
we're waiting on your vote
yeah what were the other votes
um
that's not the way we would normally do
that counsellor
because of the scenario i will give you
that
are you there
yes i'm here okay so those voting for
the motion
are counsellors arnold clark the mayor
yes keep going sorry yep those voting
against the motion are counsellors
ludlow sopa amundsen
abbott pottinger councillor crackit is
abstaining
yeah i'll vote against the motion
i'm sorry about that technical so other
technical confusion right so councillor
pottinger as chair you are in the
position of a six-all vote and you have
the casting vote
well
i've seen this bit done before where
someone with the casting vote has voted
against
what
they voted originally but i am not doing
that
and i will vote against my casting vote
on that basis the notice of motion is
lost
can i can i just say that councillor
pottinger in doing that has has abided
by the usual convention of voting for
the status quo
yes
no noted
thank you
now we move on to
the activity report since we've done the
explanation to water supply
activity report
is
multifaceted we have various group
managers
um
who would like to start this off i think
we've got a lot about leisure and
recreation with aquatic services
steve are you about
yes i am uh mr chair good afternoon
councillors um actually
look i'll just uh
take you to the key part of the report
from uh the letter and recreation group
which is a summary of
the
hydra slide and this is a question
raised by councillor cracker at the last
um infrastructure services meeting
possibly a month ago
um the question was raised around how's
the slide hydro slide performed against
the agreed business case and i think
we've been able to identify that
despite the discounting that the
business case was
fairly accurate and actually we've
exceeded what was in that business case
both in terms of repaying against the
loans but also covering its operating
costs
the thing that's mitigated against uh
possibly the starting position has been
how we've introduced the new service
and some of the challenges that we've
had to face and you'll note that we've
got
one of our slides
closed at the moment for repair to one
of the columns which was
noted last month
and
[Music]
we've also had um as with any new
facility we've opened it
and we've tried to manage um some quite
high customer demands so we've used
session times and discounting to also
support more people getting access to
the service
but as a result i think we can be fairly
confident that the business case that
set behind this back in 2018 was good
and that the performance has exceeded
that in the operations
um
happy to answer any questions on the
basis of that report or anything else
around parks and recreation
thank you steve
questions please
no question steve
okay
uh move on to
parks and recreation
anyone want to speak to that
uh back to infrastructure i think chair
okay radio aaron do you want to speak
um yes thank you chair
uh in terms of the infrastructure
component of the activity report um
there's just a couple of quick i guess
themes i would draw out of the report
one of those is in relation to
covert 19 and our lockdown
you'll see from the report that under
level 3 we have been able to
re-establish on our city center streets
upgrade
and for anybody who has been out under
level three they will have seen that
work recommencing
we also had some slight differences in
the way that we operated the transfer
station through alert level three
putting in place a booking system to
better manage the demand for that
facility
um we've been quite impressed as to how
well that system worked and we've had
some quite positive feedback around that
the other piece i just note there is
that we've done some high-level analysis
around the loss of revenue as a result
of covert 19 alert levels three and four
um and there are some high level figures
in there from that analysis uh around
the loss of half to three quarters of a
million dollars of our revenue um with
each month that we would be in in alerts
levels three and four so that just gives
some some picture around that loss of
council revenue during that time and
that uh
is it ranges from things like commercial
businesses are using less water and
therefore
receiving less water less revenue from
water to the closure of our facilities
like splash palace
the other thing i'd just like to note is
that there is an element there around we
did have an investigation with not
getting
our new
discharge to air consent in place in the
required time frame for our green waste
facility
this is an application process that has
been underway for some time but we
didn't submit it to environment
southland in a reasonable amount of time
for them to process it before the
expiration exploration
expiration i'll try that again of the
new consent
they
investigated on that basis um
and decided not to take any formal
action but we did receive a a written
warning um and some investigation costs
in relation to that one um and it was
just a bit unfortunate with uh
one of those key vacancies that i guess
we spoke to around the risk and
insurance
meeting um a couple of weeks ago just i
guess lacking the drive that we needed
to to keep that process moving in the
time frame required
the other thing i'd just like to note is
that i spoke to a previous
infrastructure committee meeting around
an outage on our continuous monitoring
of our water treatment and the fact that
there was a small risk there that when
we got an annual audit that we may be
found non-compliant due to a small gap
in our data
i'm very pleased to say that through
analysis of our backup data we've been
able to source the data that was missing
in that nine minutes which removes that
that risk of us being potentially
non-compliant at year end
so that's all i'd like to speak to if
there are any questions
thank you aaron
questions regarding
those topics
counselors
no
no questions michael's got his hand ah
sorry michael michael
hello
it's very unusual councillors for me to
be um talking in the activity report but
we have a financial section there which
um
erin alluded to with the covert
impact of on our finances um i just
wanted to highlight that uh tomorrow
going into
uh level two triggers the 14 days
periods commencing in relation to the
penalties side of it so i just wanted to
call that out it's right at the end of
the report
just so we're very clear that it is
starting from tomorrow that that 14 days
begins
thank you michael
council rabbit did you want to speak
no no i was happy to move the report
actually
okay thank you for that
right
the recommendations are that the
infrastructural services committee
receives the report activity report
note that the hydrostatic operations
have generally exceeded the original
business case
objectives
so council rabbit moved that kind of a
second to please
thank you council kit i'll put that
motion all those in favor
all right
again
that is carried thank you
right that is the end of the public part
of the
infrastructure meeting
i would like uh to move that we go into
public excluded for the reasons
uh
being
item a confirmation of the minutes of
the public excluded session of the
infrastructural
services committee held on
3rd of august
item b
ocean beach remedial issues and item c
recyclables acceptance contract
happy to second that mr chair and can i
just add mr
grant and mr mckenzie to stay in public
excluded
yes thank you i will also include those
i'll send out invitations now
right
we've moved and seconded that i'll put
that motion all those in favor
aye
aye
yes